ici un Saint-Pierre-des-Corps le cabaret
ovation propose un spectacle
époustouflant qui allie laser et cabaret
ce projet unique et l'oeuvre de Marjorie
et François un couple de passionnés
Marjorie danseuse chorégraphe François
régisseur lumière ont décidé de se
lancer dans ce projet fou afin de
proposer un spectacle futuriste alors
c'est fou comme moi vous aimez être
ébloui
époustouflez et bienvenue au cabaret on
va venir après l'action espagnole n'est
pas obligatoire mais moi j'aime bien
[Musique]
là j'ai intégré l'équipe c'est parti du
crew c'est avec les filles choqué ouais
[Musique]
le début de cette aventure de l'ovation
mais en fait on voulait vraiment créer
un lieu immersif dans le domaine du
cabaret on adore la beauté voilà toute
la tous le côté dense et tout mais on a
amené aussi toute la technique des
grosses shows qu'on peut trouver même
des techniques de Las Vegas par exemple
ton équipe sublime là tu me la présentes
un petit peu alors déjà Rebecca Lisa
Marion Lorenza et le chouchou de la
bande le seul homme que j'ai vu pour
l'instant aujourd'hui là
alors maintenant le laser je suis prêt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention
téléportation
névralgique la vidéo le son la lumière
et voilà le vaisseau mère qui vient qui
ose se plonger en immersion ici à
l'ovation le public du cabaret en
général on a l'impression que c'est les
personnes âgées mais pas que c'est
surtout avec un spectacle comme ça assez
technologique assez novateur
on a voulu élargir la cible et on a
vraiment des jeunes on a même des tout
petits petits qui viennent de voir le
spectacle en tout cas moi ta machine
elle me donne envie franchement j'ai
envie de m'éclater avec moi
incroyable
je pense qu'il va téléporter mais tu vas
pas apprécier quand même un minimum
ok je suis en chou c'est ça
[Musique]